it's a good morning everyone um I'm Alex
Villarreal the bd2k centers Coordination
Center welcome to another BBK Davis
science seminar so last time we actually
concluded section three which provided
an overview of computing and we heard
about some of the work that NIH is doing
in developing cloud-based infrastructure
to support biomedical big data science
today we actually started a new section
section 4 which is focus on data
modeling in an inference and any of
you've had to work with big data
datasets will appreciate the challenges
that are associated with understanding
the data and using it to clear patterns
and so the next few weeks we'll have
speakers talking about a range
techniques that are related to modeling
inference tasks and to kick off the
section we're joined by dr. raphael
Irizarry that professor biostatistics in
the School of Health and a member of the
Dana Farber Cancer Institute his work
focuses on genomics and computational
biology problems in particular he's
worked on analysis of microarray
next-generation sequencing and genomic
data
dr. Irizarry has developed several
online courses on data analysis that are
offered through Harvard X including the
analysis for the life sciences and
genomic data analysis so please join me
in welcoming dr. Ayers area this morning
dr. sir thank you for joining us today
ah the floor is yours thank you thank
you for inviting me all right so a quick
overview can everybody hear me just
double-checking yes
okay all right so as a quick overview so
you know what's coming I'm gonna divide
us into two parts I'm going to very
quickly review some basic inference and
modeling since this is what the lecture
is about but it's what I want to do more
than give introduction introductory
material is to show how I use it in in
my research to put it in context and I'm
gonna do it I'm going to show two parts
one somewhat simple inference basic
inference and then the second one a
little bit more advanced more complex
related to exploration and modeling and
how it's very important or how about I
have found it to be very important for
understanding and improving the quality
of information that comes out of
high-throughput measurement so I worked
in I've
working for the last 15 years mainly in
genomics with technology
developing statistical methodology for
the measurements that come out of new
technologies such as microarrays
next-generation sequencing and it's
different applications because these
technologies have many different
applications and for each one different
statistical challenges come up and it's
been data science for since I've started
it's the problems are very much driven
by the data people are using data to
discover new things so even before that
tournament aim wildly popular people in
genomics were relating to the data
science alright so there's much more
information on my webpage of what I want
to talk about and also I make
announcements on Twitter about new
research papers new courses and other
things so here's a course that was
here's a link to the course that was
described this is this one is it's free
it's a free course you can you can take
it self-paced there's there's currently
seven different courses that go in order
of difficulty starting with the simplest
one where introductory statistics is is
presented along with our code to be able
to implement that knowledge there's also
a book that goes along with that with
that course it's also free you can get
it on on lean pub and it comes down as a
PDF if you want a hard copy you can
that's not free and it's Amazon and one
nice thing about the book is that it
basically reconstruct the code you you
need to reconstruct a book with all the
data analysis in it is included on
github there's links to it and within
the book so you can not only read it and
learn statistics and compute it and
coding in order but also recreate the
book and learn that way all right
so just to get started I want to go back
to the very very small the most simplest
concept in inference and those that
already know this bear with me it only
be like five minutes and basically it
it's what I'm going to do is explain
what the little stars on top of the
buildings with antenna that we see in
scientific papers means all right so
that's what they put on on on the graph
two two two
relay that it's statistically
significant so I'm gonna just go over
that for five minutes and then explain
some subtleties with that how this has
come up in in my research so to give a
very simple example is suppose we have
two groups and basically is to make it
simple I'm gonna use men and women and
Heights and what I have is a population
of men and women and there's a there's
if you can take the mean of the man in
the mean of the women and and that that
those two means may or may not be
different but I suppose we don't know we
come from out of space and we don't know
that that's the case so we want to know
and we could just measure everybody and
and come up with an answer or we could
take a sample so if we take a sample of
ten people ten of each we then get data
so here's what it would look like here's
an example of a sample this is an actual
sample I took from with using pre pre
measured heights and we can see that
there's a difference between and one men
are taller by three inches in this
sample so inference is the part of
Statistics that helps you understand if
this is how much can this very and of it
and how consistent this is with the with
the actual means being same or different
so we basically are interested in the
means of the population so we look at
the sample means and and then use that
to try to answer the question so here's
what one way to see inference to
understand inference so we did it once
tell me I'm just going to do it for the
men Heights not for the difference for
now so with the important the important
concept to get here is that every time
we take a sample that mean changes
here's the mean of men for the first
sample I took but if I take another one
it'll be a different one I'm going to
start making a histogram where these
Heights pile up and you see that we get
different values every time and we do it
a million times
we eventually get a distribution of of
the heights so all the average heights
and we can
how much it varies it varies from around
67 to about 71 that's for 95% of the
data is outcomes are and this gives us
this tells us wait a minute we saw a
difference but they could it could have
been different
how different could have been well this
distribution helps us understand that
and that's the general principle behind
inference but understanding that the
population house the vet has variability
and that there's there's tall men and
short men etc and the fact that we take
a sample results in the average Heights
having variability as well so we if we
make the sample videos one of the things
you learn in statistics classes then the
variance of that mean gets smaller right
so you can see that this distribution is
not as fat though this is what you learn
in statistics classes that that mean and
those means both for men and women is
going to be approximately normal with
population mean standard deviation
divided by the square root of the sample
size and what this the way we use this
in biology very often is is by
constructing a T statistic and we can do
using some mathematics we might when
some modeling we can't we we know how
much that T statistic should vary just
by chance and from there we get P by
using confidence interval this is just a
reminder of what what we're talking
about here well sometimes we don't
assume normality and we use a model and
some the T distribution I'm not getting
into that yet okay so I'm going to give
you an example of how that simple
concept has and this was a a research
activity of mine a long time ago and
this it actually keeps coming up but how
the concept was not was not being
clearly understood by collaborators
other people publishing papers and we we
do a little experiment to kind of point
out the problem so I'm going to give you
an example relates to this the decision
sometimes is made by biologists or
experimental bio is to pool their
samples to reduce variance
okay so here's an experimental design
that is very common in in biology and if
we let's say now let's talk about gene
expression that's one of the topics that
I work in so we have a microwave
get an expression for 12,000 genes so we
get for each gene we got 12 measurements
now I'm going to just focus the
discussion I'm if we had just one gene
or two genes we we get we have a several
my so we want we wanted to get what we
want to find out is if a gene is
differentially explained it expressed in
two different strings so we follow the
procedure we just talked about with the
heights we get twelve mice of each
strain we're going to measure the gene
expression for a given gene and then try
to answer that question so if we say yes
do we say yes this team is
differentially expressed then that what
we're saying is if you did this
experiment in your lab you will also see
it he different that's kind of what were
saying so the but there was some there
was many of my collaborators were doing
something that actually kept them from
answering that question how was that the
case because they pulled the data they
pulled the data from the twelve mice and
then they created four technical
replicates that when I asked why I say
because that reduces variance okay now
that's if you're doing that that means
you don't understand statistical
inference and I'm going to explain why
that is so so you you you this is the
experience design we take twelve
measurements which reminds pull them and
then create four replicates of the pool
so we're once you do that you will not
see the variability across the mind so
in the case of the imagine if you're
doing this with Heights
that would be taking ten men measuring
their height taking an active measuring
their Heights ten times and then
reporting the average of the ten four
times so if you just presented this to
someone who didn't know anything about
Heights
they would think that there's no tall
man and short men is just one man and
there's a little bit of measurement
error when we measure it when we measure
them so here's here's an example this is
not a cartoon this is real this is data
from the experiment of one of the genes
of two of the genes in the microwave
these are two genes that when they look
at that they compare the two groups the
two replicated the two pairs of four
replicates that were coming from the
technical replicates these four and four
that's all you see four points four
hundred four we get these two genes with
very very small p-values that
I've seen something like this by chance
using this Jesus if we just described is
very very small
it's definitely significant both genes
are like that so we write we write a
paper we say these two editions Express
but now we get it if if if someone else
runs this experiment are they gonna see
this again it when they do it and the
answers we actually don't know why not
because now I'm going to show you the
original data is now I'm going to show
you this this is actually an experiment
we ran to kind of make this point so
what well I'm actually going to show you
this data because in the experiment we
ran we actually got kept both we get we
kept these twelve measurements these
twelve measurements these four and these
four so now look at those two genes so
that is now telling a very different
story the first gene has a lot of
variability and the second one has a
very that's less favorably this is a
much when you say it's more consistent
so he now when I look do it like this
only the one on that second gene has a
significant p-value the first one
doesn't so if someone ran this
experiment again they would actually not
confirmed in one way they probably will
if they have enough power they'll
probably will confirm gaint you so the
lesson here is you you you you want to
see the variation because it's input for
the inference you're drawing it is
important it's it's it's it's part of
the the the structure it's part of the
framework of inference that you do for
this and now we're you know this is
something that comes up over and over
again where where the variability that's
important to inference is under is not
understood and you know many mistakes
are made but because of that so here are
the two genes next to each other there's
there's there's another example I think
of two genes that are like that where
one is very consistent what the other
one is ample when you pool you know you
don't really get to see that and we
actually wrote a paper on this it's not
just about this has other things like
experiment of it's about experimental
designs when you when you want when you
need to pool this but in case it
actually explains this in more detail
and it's published in 2005 and PNAS okay
so
the the the moral of one of the models
of the story of that particular example
is that the biological variability is
much more it's much bigger than
technical variability and that's I think
that's going to be common in many many
of the measurement technologies that we
we haven't big in big data and biology
in general that we're gonna get more and
more precise technical measurements but
human variability or whatever we're
measuring will won't go away okay so one
last another thing I would like to
mention in a class about inference you
know talk about inference is the
multiple comparison problem the this is
obvious to most but I still see papers
coming out that not correct for multiple
comparisons in any way and so I want to
just briefly mention it so just just I
guess I just don't really use these
slides and I'll just describe the
problem when you have in the case of of
gene expression you have twelve many in
high-throughput sorry in the case of
high-throughput technology we are and
we're trying to find say differential
expression differentially expressed
genes could be other things it could be
differentially methylated cpgs it could
be differentially binding transcription
factor binding sites etc we're looking
at many many we're exploring of a big
space we're testing many hypotheses
that's how a statistician would say and
one thing to keep in mind is that if you
test 10,000 hypotheses and you restrict
the gene to report or whatever units you
report to 5% a p-value you're gonna get
for 500 incorrect report reporter genes
even when when sorry when the the null
hypothesis is true so if you if you
don't understand or if you've got many
of you probably are thinking yeah I know
that but if you don't know exactly what
I'm talking about here definitely go
read up on multiple comparison art we
have a course that covers it we have
it's in the book but there's many other
books and other courses it to describe
alright
all right so that's the first part of
the target in its I know it was very
basic now I want to go to some more
complicated topics the complex topics
where statistical modeling has helped
and and also exploratory data analysis
which I know it's not in the title of
the talk but it's as important or
perhaps more important and I think in
the analysis of what today we're calling
big data
I'll do it through examples in the
second part okay so the first thing I
want to I want to warn against is this
the our our desire for wanting to have
workflows this is a screenshot of what
you get on google images when you google
workflows and biology or in biomedical
sciences and it is you know I get a
bunch of things like this but if you if
you if you look at them closely many of
them are basically come down to a
workflow like this with describing a way
to go from big data to knowledge right
that's the title of the graph so you
start with big data and I knew you go
through this process is use the boxes
and at the end there's some there's some
list or some figuring and you're and
you're done are you discover something
or learn something so so what I want to
remind is one of the one of my goals
here is to remind listeners of how
important it is to think hard about what
these boxes are doing and sometimes just
make sure that they're doing what we
think we're doing it's many times the
case that the the procedures that we
think are standard procedures and we can
just stick in it stick them into the
workflow will work and it turns out that
just by looking at a few plots you
quickly realize that it's absolutely not
the case that we that this that this
actually leads to knowledge instead it
leads to false positives and confusion
so what I want to do is I want to
explain
apples of where this the workflow that
people were using without exploring data
just by kind of just turning the crank
we're leading to two problems all right
so here's a quote from John Tukey that
kind of relates to to what I just
described all right so I've to motivate
this I want to I also want to motivate
the the improvement of the of the boxes
in the work flow not just to set not
just saying we're going to keep you from
making mistakes but we actually want to
help you make discoveries it's not just
about being you know policemen or about
being a Debbie Downer about about what
people find but rather two things you'll
you'll have less less false positives
but also you will have more true
positives hopefully so to to make to
motivate that I always like to go back
to the discovery of the microscope which
led not to discover the Microsoft the
improvement of the microscope which led
the person who first improved the
microscope and enough that it led him to
become the father of microbiology so
simply by but not simply but he but one
people were looking for the microscope
the other scientist we're trying to
discover things but they were seeing
blurry images he improved the microscope
and he was able to see something that
nobody else saw and now discovers
microbes he discovered a bit many many
other things that are microscopic
because he was the only one that could
see them so in in how am I feeling in
high throughput biology I feel like the
data scientists are often not just
keeping people from making false claims
but also helping people put their data
into focus and make and make discoveries
so here's another quote from Turkey
related to that particular topic and it
goes when it comes to data which is what
we look at now we don't look through
microscopes anymore I know some people
do we look at data we have digital data
that the data scientists turn into
images at then biologists or other
scientists turn into knowledge or
extract knowledge from and in making
figures is exploring data is a key
component of doing that
properly so I'll give you now concrete
examples from my own research related to
this to what I did subscribe I'm gonna
talk about two problems to two examples
and there's many more which I won't have
time to talk about you want to read more
about my own personal experience in this
I have you know a lot of my current
papers related to this particular topic
and you're of course welcome to to go
look some of those up now and I think
it's happening all over the sciences
it's not just in genomics it's not just
in biology but improvement of data
analysis pipelines by careful data
exploration is in thinking of how to
properly models data is leading to a lot
of improvements in and how we interpret
data
okay so here's an example this is again
not a cartoon this is actual date this
is actually date experimental data I'll
explain what it is now so the data that
I'm presenting in this plot comes from
public repositories it's this particular
one is a gene expression omnibus and
this is a great resource it has all any
published gene expression experiment is
supposed to be in you neither geo or
another European database called array
Express so you can go there and now what
I did for this one as I went there and I
got data from five different tissues so
there's five different tissues
represented in this in this figure and I
obtained gene expression data from them
for not from microwaves in this case and
they are so that means I have for each
sample I have twelve thousand
measurements so it's a twelve thousand
number vector and I have more than five
points because for each tissue
I had several individuals so there's
about fifty points because for each
tissue about I have about ten people on
average so so I have these vectors I
have I have about fifty sectors that are
in ten thousand-plus dimensions right
there's a house one number for each gene
so that's something I can't really flop
so instead I'm going to plot the first
two principal components that's what I'm
showing here of that big matrix if you
don't know what
principal components are is a very very
simple explanation of one of the things
you can do with them so you have in each
point here represents one of the samples
that is originally 12,000 dimensions I
have reduced it to two dimensions those
12,000 and the nice property about these
particular this particular summary is at
the distance between any two points
resembles the distance between the
original twelve thousand dimension
vector so so so now I want to have it in
two dimensions accurate actually see
what's close and what's not close
so in this plot I can see that these
points are close and then we have that
these points are close these points are
close etcetera so these points are close
so that I would tend to think well those
are probably from the same tissues
different tissues have different gene
expression patterns that's one of the
reasons there they become different
tissues in the first place so I should
see here five clusters I don't quite see
them now I'm going to reveal what the
tissues are and you can see that it's
not really what we were expecting all
right so these guys that were close
together are different tissues these are
: and these are the center and we have
some colons down here that are way
farther from these colons and they are
from here I so you can see other
problems in the data so I would say that
this data is out of focus or this fact
that we thought we knew about gene
expression and tissues is maybe not true
so if you just go around the pipeline
the workflow and run this data through
and and and ask for clusters you
conclude biologists are wrong gene
expression between tissues is not that
different and that would be a mistake so
because if we then dig deeper into the
data forget the workflow let's go back
to the data and dig deeper into it we're
going to find that there's a lot of
noise in the measurement so now we're
going to take one point just and we're
instead of just reducing it to two
dimensions we're actually going to look
at all the data all the 12,000 points
and this figure shows you that it shows
you so now we have the 12,000 points you
can see there's 12,000 little black
and the plot is is made in in a way that
reveals what we are interested in when
we look at compared to samples you have
what's what genes are different in one
which ones are not we have the log ratio
of the two measurements on the y-axis so
for example this gene is 16 it's log
base 2 this gene is 16 times bigger on
one that one sample compared to the
other and isn't that are at zero are the
same log ratios there all right so this
particular data set is is not one of the
ones that you just saw this is an this
is from an experiment that the
accompanying gran and we were in there
were nice enough to share with us just
to test out the technology and what's
what was done for this experiment was
they took each G they took two samples
that that were the same how do they know
they were the same because they took
they took one RNA sample one one one big
of out of a material that had RNA
molecules in it and they randomly split
it into two they just split it into two
equal parts and then they ran the
experiment on those two so if the
technology is working well there's
enough molecules there that the things
were at will average out in and it
should be the case that when you compare
them when we run a measure gene
expression in these two it's basically
the same sample we should get the same
answer for every gene so this mass of
points should really be around zero
close to zero now you can say well sure
there's measurement error okay that's
that's very possible however the the
people who ran this experiment included
12 16 genes these are the orange ones
they represented in orange here where
they knew they were actually different
they made them twice as big for real for
real
they actually artificially made them
twice as big in one sample compared to
the other so these 12 these 12 points
are the ones that should be different
the black point should be at 0 and these
black point should be at 1 so this gives
you an idea of what signal looks like
and here this is a problem now if the
signal is this big then this is a
problem because if I gave you this
picture and I said
find me the 20 most differential genes
you would probably say well this one and
that one and this one and these these
are all big you will never come down to
this to these twelve to these sixteen so
there's a lot of noise in the data so
why is that why is there so much noise
in the data is it is it is this just a
way by audience or is this the way that
that the technology works and if it
doesn't we might as well stop buying
this product well so to answer this
question one of the things we did was go
even one step further down the data
these points actually are come from even
raw data and we read how that was done
how they actually got to here and we
noticed that there was some modeling
going on there was statistical modeling
happening when when they when they
analyzed the data to get to these points
so here's here's sort of what the model
was for doing this so what what was
happening is that these measurements the
the manufacturers realized that when
they were trying to measure the
expression of a specific team they were
they were also measuring background
noise so even when a gene was not
expressed the unit that was measuring
that gene which sure would give values
big values sometimes and they also
noticed that different measurement units
produce different background levels
which was a problem because now when you
have different gene expression
measurements in two different genes it
might be the only reason you might be
seeing that is because you were just had
two units that worked that way and that
one measured high background the other
measure no background so they they
thought of it like this the model they
thought about was like this you had you
wanted to estimate gene expression he
represented with the beta but there's
background that's represented with the
Alpha and every single measurement every
single different you measurement you
only have a different alpha so - so it
wasn't like a global alpha that can
remove you have to remove an alpha for
each single measurement every unit had a
different one every measurement you had
a different one so to get that out so if
you just see if you see what if your
serum is
seven you don't know if that's four plus
three or two plus five you have no way
of knowing that so to determine that
what they did was they said let's
construct this add measurement units to
the to this instrument that measures
just the background so now we have we
have two measurements one measures the
background plus the signal the other one
just measure the background and what
we'll do then is we'll subtract it and
we'll get B and we're done don't try
themselves well here's a problem with
that model if you take we did another
experiment just to get an idea of how
how off this model was is it the problem
here is that there's no stochasticity
described in the model so we said that
we ran an experiment where that we knew
there was no beta we were an experiment
that was just a negative control and in
that case we should just be seeing alpha
and alpha so here's a plot of that and
you can see that it's not right on the
line it's it's correlated that's good
but it's quite a bit of noise this is in
the log scale so that's quite a bit of
noise that you're seeing there between
between y1 and y2 measured y2 and white
y1 and y2 is measurement of alpha so the
problem with this is that the actual
model should look something like this
since there's an hour now this is
actually a statistical model where
there's randomness included we have
alpha 1 alpha 2 not just alpha alpha
they're different they're different
quantities they're correlated in the log
scale the correlation is about 0.7 you
can see that's chlorine there is about
point seven so if that's the case if the
correlate if that's a model that's a
model that to us makes more sense that
implies that if you then look at things
like log ratios which is what people
were using to to to quantify differences
in gene expression then the variance of
that of the log of that difference right
because that's what they're they're
using as a measurement the difference
between one why I went to the variance
of the log of that difference we can
show mathematically I'm not going to
show you here it's using something
called Taylor expansion it's important
we can show that
that variance is proportional to the
reciprocal of the signal squared that's
Northam Attucks that's not biology
that's not problems of the technology
it's the problem with the decision they
made the mathematical decision they made
of how to correct this measurement so if
you look at this this formula then you
can see that that you see it here if you
if you draw a line of the variance here
you just go by the points if you draw a
line of the variance it would go like
that that is that function is 1 over x
squared well it could be some some
constant we would need some constant but
it's very consistent with what the math
is predicting 1 over B squared 1 over B
squared this would be B right this is
the signal average the average of the of
the two measurements is an approximation
of the signals so that that in mind now
that we if we have them now that we have
a model we can come up with a better
statistical solution that doesn't have
this property we can do that we have a
model in place now we can do math and
figure out ok what transformation of the
data would estimate data without having
a massive variance and we might
introduce a little bit of bias just to
reduce the variance that's one approach
that is awfully used in statistics in
machine learning that's called shrinkage
or regularization and when we do that
just with that with with that in mind we
can construct them a solution based on
the model and we can go from this plot
to this plot that's without any new
experiment or any kind of nothing new
just the same data process differently
we get rid of all that noise that we
were seeing earlier and now if we ask
you to give me the biggest differences
you would definitely start with some of
these orange points so that's quite a
big improvement so that again that was
just the result of the changing the way
you model the data and develop
statistical solutions for it so that
that idea was turned into software and
and now and now today when people use
these technologies most not still not
everybody but most I would say use a
technique like this rather than and they
it was originally proposed
all right so that's one example of how
the statistical models can improve
measurement the it data that you then
use to to make this biological discovery
for example let's go back to the to the
motivation to the motivation example
here the the data that we started with
which I would say is really out of focus
data and this is process with the
original algorithm once I use this new
idea this new idea that comes from from
a more rigorous statistical model you
end up with a plot that looks like this
and that is now much more consistent
with what biologists told us gene
expression patterns from the same tissue
are similar to each other and they're
different from different tissues we see
the five clusters varies clearly if we
didn't know that we would actually
discover it because if you looked at
this data without the colors you would
be pretty sure there's four maybe five
clusters and then you would be on to
something
all right so now moving on to a another
way in which statistical modeling helped
us quite different I like to talk about
this one because it's I think currently
the biggest challenge in genomics is
dealing with what we call the batch
effect and I suspect we're gonna see
about effects in pretty much any kind of
measurement technology that is collected
across time and you'll see what I mean
as I as I describe this okay so I'm
gonna use an example this is a paper
that you use the standard workflow they
took they filed all the best practices
they had raw data they processed it with
a recommended processing algorithm they
did t-tests correctly then they did
before any correction so they dealt with
a multiple comparison problem in a very
conservative way and even after that
they they report even after that
conservative use of some phony to not
make type 1 errors they they conclude
that 1097 of the 4,000 and 187 years
that they tested I show a statistically
significant difference between two
different ethnic groups when you measure
gene expression and blood so that is
that's a big number it's contrary to
what most people would think was the
case I think if you ask somebody before
this paper was published how many things
are differentially expressed between two
ethnic groups they would probably say
between zero and maybe five that's like
that's what I would have answered
instead they get a thousand so they got
their paper published in a in a very
prominent statistical Journal of
biological journals because it's a
surprising result all right so now let's
forget the workflow and let's go back to
the data and look at it so I you can
even actually get this data from geo
this is the data from that paper you can
see there's about 200 points 209 I think
so each point now does it's not a
different tissue each point is a
different person and I can each person
has a profile of the Aesir out of 4,000
but I think the original number was
8,000 that they filter down so this is a
technology that measured about 8,000
gene expression genes expression for so
we have event for each person you have a
vector of 8,000 and I and then I we
reduce it down to 2 for PC I just to
take a look first look at the data and
we can see that the results here is very
consistent with what they were saying
about 1,000 genes being different
because there's a very clear difference
between the two ethnic groups being
compared you have the orange and
compared against the green the first
principal component is very different
that that would probably that to me is
very consistent with what they problem
with what was published now if we're
looking at this data there's something
else that catches our eye and it's that
we see other clusters not just the
ethnic groups if you look closely at the
orange group which is all the same
ethnic group
you see I see at least I see a cluster
here and a cluster here and then I move
here there's another cluster here and
you can kind of see another one here so
but regardless of that if if this group
is shows this much variation why is this
group showing this much variation that's
a lot more that's double or triple so
when you see a picture like that you
start wondering what else could be
explained is difference and in this case
there's a group of scientists it wasn't
it wasn't my group it was another group
that that decided to note it I don't
know how they originally noted this but
they noted that these samples were
processed across five or six years and
it turns out that when you get the raw
data for it through this you can
actually get the state it's actually
stamped on the file where the data lives
and when you pluck now I'm going to show
you the same plot points aren't going to
move all I'm going to do is change the
color to represent date year instead of
ethnic group okay so now when I do that
I can see that those two clusters that I
they're at current I could see before
right here and here one greenish and the
other ones orange that's 2002 and this
is 2003 so that's that that was a moment
in which the measurements were made not
when the people were born or anything
like that it's just technical then we
see 2004 here 2005 2006 so is it is that
is this fair really that we see
described by by is it really just a date
the batch is we call them batch effects
because these are things that were
processed in batches it wasn't just done
once so this particular experiment is
it's a little bit hard to distinguish
between ethnicity and date because it's
confounded if you go back and forth you
see that the the orange points coincide
with the green and orange here and that
the the green coincide with the pink so
they were basically done in different
years so when you compare two things
it's hard to tell is a year or is it
ethnicity now to do what you can do
marks more data exploration and if you
do I think you'll be convinced that it's
probably date what's what's what's
making this so variable here's one
example this is the first principal
component stratified now I'm going
further instead of a year I'm doing it
by month so this is one ethnic group
here all these orange ones and you can
see that the first principal component
drops dramatically in February of 2003
and then it drops again in April and
then it kind of stays there so maybe
they were buying boxes of whatever we
don't know what it was but you can
definitely see that there's there's a
big change within the group which is
explained by month so when you when I
see a picture like this I say well I'm
gonna have to I want I want to do this
experiment again I'm going to balance
everything and and see if I get a
different answer alright so now let's
explain is with with inference and
statistical modeling this batch effect
which is a big cutest in high throughput
technology measurements and beyond one
thing I should mention is we as an aside
we can see the batch effect very clearly
in high throughput technology in low
throughput technologies it's not always
obvious but it's it's harder to see if
it is there so in a way the high
throughput technologies may be being
negatively affected because of the fact
that they reveal something because
they're more informative you actually
can see the problems when it's not as
informal it's low proof or you actually
you might be there but you don't see it
so don't think this is just a problem
with high throughput data it's just that
we can see what I throughput there I'm
gonna give you an example of a low
throughput experiment they had a huge
batch effect in a second alright so
here's here's the general I just to
write it down it with in with the
inference model with a statistical
modeling approach of why this is a
problem and it's and I'm going to write
it in more general terms so I I'm
interested in the difference between two
groups in this case it was two ethnic
groups but it could be something else i
earlier did two strains of mice and
before that we did two sexes or genders
so you have two groups Group one and
group two and we're going to take
several measurements for each one we're
going to take several individuals from
each one so that's what the eye is
indexing so we have several measurements
for one several measurements or two and
when I am assuming is that or the way
I'm modeling this is that there's a mean
there's a mean value for that group
alpha and then there's differences
between individuals which I'll describe
with this term here this is sometimes
called measurement error but in the case
of heights or gene expression its its
other its other things it's not just
measurement error in the case of heights
it's some people are tall so they have a
bigger epsilon some people are sure so
they have a negative episode all right
then the second group has that has the
same mean and perhaps that's what we're
going to test it has a difference that
is characterized with the beta and then
they also have measurement so what I'm
looking for I'm looking for genes or in
the previous case I was looking for
genes that had betas different from zero
and reporting those alright so how do I
find beta we already went over this but
here we go again we the difference
between the two means of the two groups
is gonna be approximately beta the
alphas cancel out the Epsilon's average
out to zero if we take enough
measurements so this is approximately
beta and what we did with the t-test is
to go further and say well it's paid up
but we also know that it has a standard
error which has to do with the
population variance and the size of the
sample that's the standard statistical
approach to doing this but and that's
what that was done for this previous
example we talked about when they were
looking for genes they were different in
the two groups
now when you
about the fact that model is no longer
correct instead and in here I'm Alex I'm
showing an example where the batch
effect was confounded meaning that Group
one had was done in one batch group two
was done in another batch so this this w
that I'm showing you here is the
potential difference introduced by being
in a different batch know that there's
no I so each batch has its own main
value so if I have this if this is my
correct model then I have a problem
because this is no longer the case I no
longer the alphas okay this should be
alpha sorry this guy here the Alpha is
no longer cancel out the epsilon is my
I'm sorry the office do cancel out the
Epsilon's are still average out to zero
but these w's they stay so what I'm when
I when I look at the difference in the
average what I'm seeing is the what I'm
the difference I'm interested in plus
the difference in the value in the
average values introduced by the batches
so if I look at these differences and I
see a five I don't know if it's 2 plus 3
or 0 plus 5 or or 5 4 0 I have no way of
distinguishing that I can't have no
information I have no way of separating
that out when it's completely confounded
so that's that's the that's the problem
with comes with with confounding batches
with with outcomes and not have on 14
that happens a lot in these experiments
where they get all the controls and they
run them first and then then get all the
treatments and run a second I see it all
the time this this this tip type of
confounding another way to think to
think about this for those that are or
event statistically is to think that
these double use are random variables so
it's like a random effect that each
batch introduces it's it's it's it's the
same across across batches so the way
this is then turns into into a
description of the problem is that the
variants that we estimated for our
estimate is bigger there's a variance
due to W then what we actually use for
teachers which is this this component so
when we constructed teachers with this
variance were under estimating the
variance and therefore we get our T
tests are bigger than they should
that's another way to think about this
okay
so here's an example just earlier I said
this is not this is not specific to high
throughput here's an example from
physics experiments from the last
century so what this this is data from
from that that you can get from a paper
published in techno metrics by udin in
1972 he actually has a table of these
values and I turn into figures and they
are the reported estimates of the
astronomical unit along with a
confidence interval so this is what
today we think is the astronomical unit
this is shown here in this dashed line
and here is the first experiment that at
least in this paper was reported and
then here's the second one and we can
see that the speed of light either
either there's a front there's something
wrong with either the estimates of the
confidence intervals or the speed of
light changed in in 1900 then you can
see it happen again right cuz it this is
definitely statistically significant
here's it again it changed again in 1920
this feel like change cetera so that is
a problem and if we just looked at this
guy with no other information we
wouldn't know what's going on but once
we make the whole plot this is now we
turned it into a high-throughput
experiment with many labs measuring it
we see the problem and it's that there's
like there's a lab effect it's a batch
effect depending what lab did it we get
a deviation from what today is
considered to be the right answer
so the promise the lab that we're
measuring these with in their lab they
can't see that they have this batch
effect so the confidence intervals that
they report are much smaller than what
they should be so here's here's another
way to think about it this this variance
that we see here this variance that we
see here is estimated with as a
measurement error variance so we get it
from within the experiment that would be
their intercept the measurement
well the batch effect variance W is much
bigger that's why the points are wearing
all over the place all right so I there
there are some solutions that have been
developed for this problem they are but
they're based on something called factor
analysis it is actually a very old
technique from the 1900s and early 1900s
and and the reason that this technique
is is why they use is because when we
look at the data this is this is a plot
of the correlations between the 200
individuals from the previous example
and you can see that there's there's
blocks of groups that are more
correlated to each other all right so
that this this must be like the first
two years this is like 2005 is that you
can see in these blocks of time but then
there's a sub blocks it's all this
structure you see like tight red dots
not as type it's somewhat pinkish big
squares so there's a structure in the
data that makes this that makes that is
induced by some kind of weird grouping
that have to do with date but it's not
clear that it's just date so when you
have a problem like that factor analysis
what it tries to estimate is structure
and then take it into account when
you're doing the analysis so I'm going
to try to explain that in five minutes
so we can finish with five minutes for
questions and to describe this approach
and give you an idea of how how complex
this is I'm gonna use a subset of the
earlier data set of 200 people I'm gonna
take 24 of them I'm gonna take 12 men
and 12 12 females and 12 males all right
so you can see they're sparing to the
design here I'm going to confound eight
but not completely so these techniques
work when they is if something is
completely confined we're we currently
don't have any any solutions but if it's
not there's you can use statistical
models to help so here is a here's you
can see the confounding here more males
were measured in June and in females and
more females are measured
over the mails all right so this plot is
another cartoon this is again actual
data from the from the experimental data
you can see genes I have selected some
genes I didn't I'm not showing you all
8,000 and you can see me act the y-axis
up here the Y sorry the Y chromosome
okay these are genes on the Y chromosome
males are high
females are low because females don't
have a white chromosome I said that
there are the 12 men and a 12 women and
12 males 12 females and then this is
these are genes on the Y chromosome then
we see other genes and there's no
difference you know you can see in some
variability and then down here you can
see the dates these are genes that are
affected by the batch effect so let's
look at that so can you tell where our
June is you can see it here see this
square here there's nine people here
nine men these nine men we're done in
June they're right here and then these
three these three men I'm sorry these
three men right here they're blue
you see October and June actual this is
June in October right for the females
there's three in June and 9 October so
you can see the batch effect so what
happens if I do a t-test now just
ignoring this if I compare this side to
that side these are going to be super
significant but so are these because
there's more red here than over here so
like if I if I fit this is the model
this is another way of writing out the
t-test model if I assume this I get this
this air is gonna cause problems for me
if I make a histogram of p-values I get
a lot of significant genes main when I
look at the autism genes I'm really not
expecting many or any at all and I it's
driven probably by the fact that we have
the difference between you and October
so you can see you can see the sample
correlations again here so here's or
here's the original ordering with
females and males ordered back like that
the correlations not explained by it is
explained by date so if I if I order
than by day you can see June and October
two big red boxes there's more
correlation in the ones with in October
more correlation the ones in June but we
can't just model it as June and October
because there's subgroups so there's
another subgroup here that apparently
ended in October 23 or right before or
in the morning on October 2 June 23 and
then it stops and then there's another
little box here you can see some tiny so
it's basically what I'm saying is it's
not as simple as just dates there's some
other thing going on what factor
analysis does is is try to estimate this
structure so what we do is we add
another component it's it's it's a
linear component know what I mean by
that and it basically tries to model
this structure with a linear model where
you're actually estimating the the
matrix that describes the variability
this is a little more complicated it's
PCA works for estimating these
components and and that's what basically
factor analysis does what's new what's
new and what the reason there's
publications in 2007 as opposed to just
saying let's just use factor analysis
because we have we have to now
distinguish between finding being it
model we have to model the the part that
has to do with the biology that we care
about so we want to estimate the
difference between males and females so
we include that we don't want that to
just be thrown into the factor part and
then we model this part down here with a
factor model and then estimating and
fitting this model is complicated in
there that's why there's publications
because there's different approaches for
doing this and different techniques
there's several there are several papers
but here's here's a the result of
applying one of them know that now the
this this is now flattened now that's
good it means it removed most of the
genes that we think we're due to the
batch effect that's what happens when
you you apply this model to this data so
we reduce the number of false positives
by hundreds all right so here's what
it's doing it's this factor analysis
approach is splitting the data up into
the the the differences due to sex you
can see them up here I think
to false positives or maybe not so you
have the two the two differences the
sexes then you have the batch effect
here and now you have the measurement
error over here so it breaks down the
data pretty well into the different
parts all right so uh repeat it it is
repeated sorry so this is all we have
this we wrote a review on these methods
it's it's it was probably about five
anymore and and you're gonna go read it
so it's a it's described in pretty in
relatively simple terms so that you can
be aware of what what the problem is in
some of the solutions exist but this is
an area of current research the fact I'm
doing a lot of research today related to
solving a problem and different
technologies three examples listed here
you're gonna see more I have you can
follow I'll announce whatever we put out
and Twitter and also at some point the
the links go up on our web page alright
so I want to stop there thanks some
other people that helped me with the
research I described today and of course
the NIH for funding a lot of this work
ok that's the end
great thank you dr. Eric for this
wonderful start to section for for data
science in ours I think we have time for
one quick question um it's a little bit
of a provocative question but the
question is is really about sort of the
natural tension that exists between
exploratory data analysis and and
knowledge discovery and whether there's
sort of what is what is the sort of
natural balance between discovering
knowledge simply through data science
and and needing additional sort of
consummatory analyses or experiments
could you comment a little bit on that
maybe me oh sure I the way I work I
always work with collaborators that
understand the in context and the
substance of the students a substance
but the the name the the subject matter
that we're studying and that helps the
great's
greatly help
what we're finding how to make some
sense it has some explanations that are
grounded in existing knowledge and of
course we definitely we definitely
encourage our collaborators to to new
confirmation analysis when possible I
I'm a big I'm a big believer on
confirmation and and on replication I
don't I like the way that that's that
science becomes the the what's the word
that's used the the scientific consensus
the way that we come to it in today's in
the United States today it's not just
papers published and we believe it it's
not to papers are published and we
believe it it usually takes much more
than that and sometimes takes a group of
experts convened by the National Academy
to sit down and like read everything
that's been published think hard and put
out some statement
so in general III think that the person
asked that question is worried that we
just explore the data and find some
serendipitous result and publish it I I
I don't I don't think that's how we
should do it we should definitely
collaborate with experts and we should
also confirm and look for the future
papers to see what our results are
confirmed or not but with that said I'm
also I'm a big believer that that data
expression can lead to discovery and
Kano's and and also on the other side it
can also lead to the discovery of
problems of issues with something that's
been published because the data was had
problems that weren't taught by the
standard workflow so I hope that answers
the question no I think that I think
that's a great answer and and certainly
insightful I think looking at the body
of work rather than just as a single
sort of discovery is is really how
Sciences operates today so thank you
again so much for your time and for
giving this talk we're at ten o'clock so
we'll conclude here all right thank you
bye bye bye
you